now there is no doubt that the committee
on weaponization this is critical if
we're going to have a constitutional
republic now keep in mind some of the
most emphatic warnings about this
political rot are coming right from
inside the FBI itself here is a former
special agent she's been on this program
Nicole Parker take a look
yes
I believed I was making an impactful
difference
and every day I woke up and I embraced
being an FBI special agent until things
changed
over the course of my 12 plus years the
FBI's trajectory has transformed on
Bureau the papers the bureau's mission
it remained the same but its priorities
in governing principles shifted
dramatically
the FBI became politically weaponized
starting from the top in Washington and
trickling down to the field offices
all right so what's happening and what
will we learn in the days weeks and
months ahead here to join us is
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
with much more
November 18 2021 an FBI whistleblower
discloses to Republicans on the house
Judiciary that the FBI created a threat
tag for parents voicing their concerns
at school board meetings April 26 2022
another FBI whistleblower discloses that
the FBI employees are being run out of
the Bureau for attending conservative
political events
September 14th 2022
an FBI at whistleblower discloses that
the FBI views the Betsy Ross flag as a
terrorist symbol September 19 2022
another FBI whistleblower discloses that
the Washington field office is
deliberately manipulating January 6 case
files to make it appear that domestic
violence extremism is on the rise
November 4th 2022 another FBI
whistleblower discloses the FBI accepts
private user information from Facebook
without the user's consent and
information is from only the
conservative side of the political
Spectrum
this is only a sampling now on top of
all of that high-ranking officials at
the FBI they put their thumbs on the
scale in the past two presidential
elections remember let's go back to
2016. remember they smeared slandered
Donald Trump uh then of course the fisa
warrants the fisa applications they
spied on his campaign his transition
team and yes when he was in the white
house as your president and they did it
by using a fisa warrant that was full of
misinformation uh that was Russian
disinformation paid for by Hillary
Rodham Clinton and by the way by the way
Not only was it not verified it was
unverifiable because all of it was
forced so they used Christopher Steele's
dirty dossier filled with Russian
disinformation remember that was bought
and paid for paid for by Hillary as the
basis of that Russia collusion
investigation into Trump trump now early
October they had been warned in August
of 2016 by Bruce Orr don't trust us that
it's a political document they didn't
listen in October 2016 before the
presidential election in early October
they flew over the pond and they asked
Christopher Steele can you corroborate
this if you can we will give you a
million FBI dollars he never got his
money because he could never corroborate
it and guess what then by the end of
that month in October of 2016 just
before the 2016 presidential election
they used it as the bulk of information
for the fisa application at the top of a
fisa application it says verified they
couldn't support they couldn't prove any
of it and since then it has all been
disproven and by the way thankfully
Hillary Clinton was so toxic she still
lost the election even though the FBI
put their thumb on the scale as for the
33 000 emails that she deleted with
bleach bit and the devices that were
destroyed by Hammers and the SIM cards
that were removed from the devices
remember Jim Comey no prosecutor would
ever prosecute but what he meant to say
is no prosecutor will ever prosecute a
Democrat but if you're a republican it's
a whole different ball game that's where
we are in the state of America I don't
care if you're Republican Democrat
liberal conservative that should concern
everybody and you might recall December
2019 real evidence of public corruption
handed over to the FBI that's when the
FBI December 2019 got a hold of Hunter
Biden's laptop from hell now it was
filled to the prim with details
surrounding all these sketchy foreign
business ventures most of which he had
no experience at all whatsoever for
including implicating and evidence
connecting his own father the big guy to
these deals telling his own daughter uh
yeah I'm not going to do what pops is
doing to me I have to give pops half my
income wow did Joe get the money that
you made in China Ukraine Russia but
instead of validating the contents of
the laptop the FBI had it for 11 months
before the 2020 election action they
warn big Tech they had weekly meetings
with big Tech that Russian
disinformation about Hunter or Joe Biden
would soon infect their platforms now
after the New York Post blew the Scandal
wide open then we had the follow-up of
51 former Intel officials signing a
public letter claiming that the laptop
story had all the classic Hallmarks of
Russian disinformation they were lying
they had no information to back that up
at all and none of what they said was
true and now all of us deserve answers
take a look
it is important to recognize corrupt
individuals within federal agencies that
I am talking about
are not acting alone
they operate as vital partners of the
left-wing political movement that
includes most members of the mainstream
media
big Tech social media Giants Global
institutions and Foundations Democrat
Party operatives and elected officials
perhaps the most egregious and effective
Act of sabotage against the truth
was the public letter signed by 51
former intelligence officials that claim
the laptop had quote
all the classic earmarks of a Russian
information operation unquote
that letter itself
was an information operation that
interfered with and impacted the 2020
presidential election
to a far greater extent than anything
Russia ever could have hoped to achieve
in other words the 51 Intel officials
that was their disinformation campaign
and yes it did have an impact on a
presidential election in other words
Your Own federal government interfered
in the 2020 election and they tipped the
scales to the candidate they preferred
that of course would be the weak frail
cognitive mess known as Joey your
president now molt sorry I can't help
myself multiple Outlets including CBS
The Washington Post New York Times New
York Post all have confirmed the
contents in Hunter Biden's laptop is
real and now we want to know what the
big guy what was his cut in on Hunter's
pay for these you know schemes that he's
involved in and what is the FBI in doj
what are they going to do about it if
anything to this day they are seriously
you know their serious security concerns
about the Biden family business for
example here's Senator Chuck Grassley
earlier today
The Whistleblower disclosures to my
office make clear that the FBI has
within its possession very significant
impactful and voluminous evidence with
respect to potential criminal conduct by
Hunter and James Biden these disclosures
also allege that Joe Biden was aware of
Hunter Biden's business arrangements and
may have been involved in some of them
it's clear to me that the justice
department the FBI are suffering from a
political infection that if it's not
defeated will cause the American people
no longer to trust these storied
institutions let me be very clear I have
long revered the FBI I grew up you know
all four of my grandparents came from
Ireland and my grandfather's brother two
of his sons became FBI agents and they
were deity in my family the most revered
in my family we Revere it as an
institution and by the way for all the
good agents that keep our country safe
and secure every day thank you for your
great job but justice has got to be
blind and the political weaponization
that we are now seeing is never
acceptable there should be no place for
political bias at the FBI or at the
Department of Justice and it's way past
time that these Bad actors are held
accountable or this it's going to get
worse and worse until we're at the point
of no return take a look at this
we come not to trash the FBI but to
rescue the FBI from political capture
and it seems as though that political
capture was really enhanced when Robert
Mueller took a lot of the authority and
power away from the field offices all
over our country and centralized that
power seems we don't see these abuses
with a brave FBI agents like Miss Parker
who I'm very grateful served my fellow
Floridians in the Miami Field office
Miss Parker if if we got the
decision-making more out of Washington
DC and into the hands of our field
offices where we have so many patriotic
and brave FBI officials do you think
we'd be able to escape this political
capture that quite literally drove you
out of the bureau I think that's
absolutely critical it's almost as
though that politics isn't out in the
field offices it's here in Washington DC
and that's precisely what we ought to
deconstruct legislatively hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else